hiervon bild fragen uns ja wirklich wann
bin ich an der reihe
ja wir beide mutmaßlich sellin er später
wahrscheinlich also das ist das was die
wissenschaftler jetzt gerade präsentiert
haben es geht so um vier kernbereiche
ein entscheidender kernbereich oder
personen die diesen impfstoff möglichst
früh erhalten sollen am liebsten gleich
am anfang sind natürlich sehr alte
personen ältere personen haben 60 bis 70
plus dann sind natürlich personen mit
vorerkrankungen also extrem gefährdete
personen die bei einer infizierung
möglicherweise auch sterben könnten dann
geht es um das personal was sich mit
diesen kranken oder generell mit kranken
beschäftigt also ärzte pfleger
krankenschwestern die sollen auch
bevorzugt behandelt werden und es sollen
personen bevorzugt behandelt werden
die zur aufrechterhaltung des
öffentlichen lebens entscheiden
beitragen also polizisten feuerwehrleute
natürlich die mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeitern in den gesundheitsämtern
aber auch lehrerinnen und lehrer damit
der staat also weiter laufen kann man
wird auch noch mal da genau hinschauen
und dann auch entsprechend dort
frühzeitig impfen
wo es hohe übertragungsmöglichkeiten für
das virus gibt das war der vierte punkt
genannt wurde genau priorisierung war
sowieso eines der schlüsselwörter was
waren die weiteren schlüsselwörter
dieser pressekonferenz also die
priorisierung ist entscheidend weil man
natürlich sagt der impfstoff steht
irgendwann zur verfügung die
bundesregierung sagt jetzt selbst
mutmaßlich im ersten halbjahr vielleicht
auch sogar im ersten quartal 20 21 aber
auf jeden fall nicht früher das heißt
wir gehen ins neue jahr ein und werden
dann erst einen impfstoff haben und ja
und dann wird man einfach sehen es war
ein weiteres wort was viel war dieses
rollen der verfahren dieser impfstoff
der derzeit entwickelt wird es in einer
so genannten phase 3 wenn ein
pharmaunternehmen etwas entwickelt und
gibt so ein impfstoff durch verschiedene
farben der muss fahren phasen der muss
ja auch getestet werden so er ist gerade
in der letzten phase und da gibt es
idealerweise immer eine laborphase und
eine klinische testphase und normal wird
die laborphase abgewickelt dann kommt
die klinische testphase und dann schaut
man was sind die ergebnisse und jetzt
gibt es diese rolle verfahren das heißt
die laborphase sind zum teil schon
vorbei und man wertet diese ergebnisse
jetzt schon aus während aber die
klinische testphase noch läuft und das
macht man um zeit zu sparen damit kann
man sicherlich eine
einige monate zeit gewinnen und der chef
der ständigen impfkommission der hat ja
auch gerade noch mal gesagt das ist für
dieses ständige impfkommission
eigentlich ein völlig neues verfahren
was sie da hat sie muss über einen
impfstoff entscheidend der noch gar
nicht richtig auf dem markt ist sondern
geht in dieses rollende verfahren rein
also neuland auch was was die ständige
impfkommission betritt mehr nachrichten
und breaking news nur bei bate schau
dich hier das nächste video an und
vergiss nicht zu abonnieren